experten karl lauterbach ist uns nun
zugeschaltet guten tag herr lauterbach
als aller erstes möchte ich ganz kurz
auf das eingehen was wir gerade gehört
haben und zwar vor allem die eltern und
kinder wie schwer die situation für sie
ist wenn sie hören dass schulen jetzt
immer noch nicht sicher wieder
aufgemacht werden halten sie das für den
richtigen schritt dass die kinder
weiterhin zu hause bleiben müssen
zunächst einmal ich verstehe diese
situation sehr sehr gut ich bin auch
selbst getroffen durch meine eigene
tochter und das ist also eine bittere
situation aber die wahrheit ist die das
tatsächlich jetzt die schulen nicht
öffnen können zum jetzigen zeitpunkt
dann befürchten würden dass wir sehr
bald wieder zumachen müssen wir müssten
dann tatsächlich damit rechnen dass wir
eine dritte welle bekommen mit
gefährlicheren mutationen und das ist
traurig aber man kann einfach immer nur
darauf hinweisen muss dafür werben
wir sehen jetzt also dass die britische
variante und die südafrikanische
variante sogar schon kombiniert
vorkommen in england also da sich diese
beiden varianten verbunden und das
müssen wir in deutschland verhindern
dass es exponentiell lecks in der zeit
wo wir noch was sofort in impfungen sind
ich halte daher rechnungen für
grundschulen für denkbar aber es muss
vorbereitet sein das geht dann nur in
der kombination wechsel unterricht
masken und einmal pro woche einen anti
gen test bei den kindern durchzuführen
dass wir auch in der selbst der ist
unmöglich wenn man so etwas vorbereitet
hätte dann tatsächlich mehr eine öffnung
der den grundschulen zu riskieren aber
nicht ohne dass man es vorbereitet hat
und daher also ist es auch sehr wichtig
dass die schulbehörden auf die kultur
auseinander weil hier sie haben sehr
laut aber sie sprechen es an wenn man es
vorbereitet hätte wenn man ja test hätte
wenn man altenheime geschützt hätte wenn
man genug impfstoff hätte
wie kann das sein dass ein land wie in
deutschland einem jahr in der pandemie
jetzt in so vielen dingen so schlecht
dasteht ich stehe nicht in allen dingen
schlechter wir haben ja das darf man
auch sagen im vergleich zu vielen
anderen europäischen ländern haben wir
geringere sterbezahlen und
das ist also etwas worauf man doch stolz
sein aber nichtsdestotrotz also es ist
halt so
die einkaufspolitik der impfstoffe durch
die europäische union kann man in meinen
augen also nicht unkritisch sehen das
habe ich auch selbst oft vorgetragen und
mich wundert ist tatsächlich auch etwas
das also in vielen bundesländern
was die schulen angeht die
vorbereitungen nicht weiter sind dass
sie sind das ist aber nicht die
zuständigkeit des bundes also ich
beklage dass ja selbst und genau mit
vielen in kontakt aber es gibt dort eben
zum teil relativ langsam voran ich
verstehe daher aber den unmut der bürger
ohne wenn und aber
ich kann allerdings so als epidemiologe
und das 8 und das politiker hier in der
verantwortung kann ich nur sagen wir
können jetzt nicht also ungeschützt
öffnen und daher muss druck aufgebaut
werden die schulen müssen verstehen dass
es einfach jetzt zu gefährlich ist mit
30 kindern in einer klasse zu betreiben
und zu glauben das problem sei durch
lüften zu lösen das ist das definitiv
nicht dann hätten wir sehr schnell auch
ausbrüche in den schulen und wir würden
die eltern die lehrer und sogar die
kinder gefährden
denn auch für die kinder ist es nicht
ohne noch einmal einhalten ich glaube
das grundproblem der menschen ist doch
dass sie das vertrauen verlieren in die
politik wir erinnern uns alle an den
berühmten herbst lockdown wo man uns
gesagt hat ja jetzt machen wir vier
wochen lockdown und dann können wir
gemütlich weihnachten feiern
jetzt erleben wir einen endlos ewig
lockdown und sie sagen die mutation ist
so gefährlich dass wir das nicht können
dann ist doch die frage wenn die
mutationen dann so zuschlägt wie sie
sagen dann geht das ja noch monate
vielleicht bis ins nächste jahr da muss
man doch mal jetzt nicht langsam ehrlich
machen und sagen leute wir haben vor
euch noch mindestens mehrere monate in
diesem loch daran zu belassen warum sagt
man das nicht so klar
zunächst also zum noch entlocken also da
hat nicht so gut gewehrt wie er gedacht
haben aber ihr habt tatsächlich gewirkt
wir haben die zahl infektionen damals
stabilisieren können und wir haben auch
um weihnachten herum haben wir nicht so
viele neue infektionen gab die andere
länder wie zum beispiel portugal oder
andere länder wo es dann sehr schnell
abgegangen ist
womit man darf auch die erfolge nicht
kleinreden aber ich stimme ihnen zu dass
die leute zu recht die nerven verlieren
und also das geht uns allen so wie es
hier muss eben in den schuh das erste
was wir öffnen können sind tatsächlich
die grundschule und geht das muss aber
vorbereitet zahlen und diese
vorbereitung habe ich ja eben
geschrieben das muss die kombinationen
wechsel unterrichtet antigen test seien
die anti gen test sind da ihr können
auch als im vorderen nasenbereich
gemacht werden dafür muss man nicht bis
hinten in den rachen hinein das ist bei
kindern durchführbar
das kann dann organisieren da sind die
länder schlicht in der pflicht
aber wenn wir jetzt darauf schauen was
aktuell passiert hinter den kulissen wir
erleben das jetzt einfach mal das datum
auf den 14 märz gelegt wird keiner weiß
so richtig warum am anfang war vom
ersten märz die rede
dann erleben wir dass bei schulen die
kanzlerin sich oft nicht durchsetzen
konnte der noch vor wenigen tagen hat
sie gesagt schulen dürfen auf keinen
fall öffnen
und jetzt wird es in die hand der länder
gelegt und wir hören das aber friseure
möglicherweise am ersten märz und
vielleicht schon früher öffnen können
wie soll man das alles verstehen als
bürger und wo ist da die logik
noch sind die beschlüsse ja nicht
gefasst aber die position die ja so
gebunden die also vorgetragen worden ist
es ja dass wir die schulen noch nicht
öffnen und erst vorbereiten dass wir
eine saubere vorbereitung haben aus rein
allen und ist wenn dann glaube ich in
vorbereitung nämlich einmal pro woche
antigen test und eben die also situation
in den wechsel unterricht überzugehen
und in sachsen in sachsen ist ja hat
herr kretschmann schon angekündigt dass
eröffnen will auch in anderen
bundesländern sollen die schulen öffnen
also das stimmt ja nicht dass überall
jetzt abgewartet wird
nein aber ich sage ihr dass wir das was
ich richtig gefunden hätte das jemand
wie kretschmann tatsächlich so vor
gericht danach gehen wir vor kurzem noch
gesagt hat er hätte aus seinen fehlern
gelernt ist natürlich enttäuscht und
alles andere wäre gelogen wenn ich das
hier verbreiten würde es ist
enttäuschend dass man also quasi hier
fakten versucht zu schaffen noch bevor
wir hier also die beschlüsse gemeinsam
gefasst haben und gerade sachsen geht
hier stark ins risiko das kann ins auge
gehen
dann wird es aber sicherlich wieder so
sein dass man dann sagt man hätte
gelernt man sonst nicht ich kann somit
die situation der bürger verstehen das
nervt ihr braucht nun eine
bundeseinheitliche linie
herr lauterbach wir wollen jetzt von den
schulen noch mal zu einem anderen thema
kommen wo wir jetzt tatsächlich mal gute
nachrichten verkünden können wenn man zu
sagen möchte und zwar die bei und tech
produktion in deutschland besser gesagt
ja jetzt in marburg das werk dort kann
jetzt gestartet werden noch früher als
wir alle gedacht hätten und bevor wir
darüber sprechen wollen wir uns da erst
mal die ersten einblicke von der
impfstoffproduktion hier in deutschland
an
bayern check hat mit der produktion
seines corona impfstoffs und seinem
neuen werk in marburg begonnen mehr als
einem monat früher und auch größer als
ursprünglich geplant auf dem werk lasten
große hoffnungen denn von hier sollen
die impfstoffdosen kommen die
deutschland endlich aus dem
schneckentempo beim empfohlen sollen
besonders für ältere hochrisikogruppen
wird der band tag im stoff dringend
benötigt marburg ist das größte biotec
eigene werk erst vor zweieinhalb monaten
war der umbau beantragt worden
wie das unternehmen gegenüber bild
bestätigte ist der probebetrieb
mittlerweile abgeschlossen bis das werk
allerdings unter volllast laufen kann
wird es noch einige wochen dauern
anfang märz könnte der erste marburg
impfstoff in die impfzentren kommen wenn
die eu arzneimittelbehörde die
produktionsstätte zulässt bis dahin wird
auf vorrat produziert
bisher kam die hauptproduktion des
impfstoffs von bayern tech partner
kaiser ich hab gesagt das gut ist es
wird produziert wir haben aber auch
gerade gehört noch wird dieser impfstoff
nicht verwendet und auch wenn er dann ab
märz verwendet wird muss wer trotzdem
weiterhin sagen wir haben in deutschland
nicht genug impfstoff es wird noch
extrem lange dauern bis vor allem die
jüngere menschen dann geimpft werden
dieses ganze im thema wie sehen sie das
vor allem in den letzten tagen wie sehr
hat die regierung da
auf die kritik auch richtig reagiert und
was denken sie kann jetzt vielleicht
sogar noch verbessert werden um die
fehler die in der vergangenheit gemacht
worden sind noch so gut es geht
irgendwie jetzt in den griff zu bekommen
also ich spreche hier nur zu den
verbesserungen ich gebe der regierung
und niemanden noten ich bewerte niemand
sind was ich kritisiere niemand dass es
nicht meine aufgabe
aber ich kann auch sagen was man machen
muss also wir sind hier in der ersten
impfwelle wir werden aber sehr schnell
erneut impfen lassen
und zwar deshalb weil die mutationen
dazu führen dass wir die impfstoffe
anpassen müssen entweder durch eine so
genannte dritte impfung booster impfung
oder sogar die komplett neue impfstoffe
somit das problem was wir derzeit sehen
dass man langsam nur impfen kann weil
wenig impfstoff zur verfügung steht und
der zu langsam produziert wird und gegen
funk zu langsam ist das können wir uns
nicht ein zweites mal leisten
es muss daher jetzt die kapazität
ausgebaut werden dass wir deutlich
schneller produzieren können weil wir
mehr werke haben so dass wir sozusagen
die geschwindigkeit der entwicklung
neuer impfstoffe auch übertragen können
auf die produktion und auch den
eigentlichen im vorgang auch der im
vorgang muss in der logistik massiv
verbessert werden wenn das wird nicht
die letzte im grunde zahlen wir sehen
mittlerweile dass es doch viel mehr
mutationen basars co2 gibt das
ursprünglich gedacht und auch
gefährliche und wir sehen jetzt zum
beispiel eine kombination der britischen
unter südafrikanischen also mutationen
im süden von england das ist sehr
riskant und daher werden wir einfach
darauf angewiesen seien deutlich größer
im kapazitäten aufzubauen müssen vom
staat auch von wirtschaftsminister
unterstützt werden so dass wir einfach
mehr geld in die hand nehmen um
schneller impfstoffe produzieren zu
können und dies zu verhelfen
das ist sehr wenig sehr laut aber wir
haben heute bei bilderseite zwei gebiete
der gipfel der gescheiterten merkel und
sparen reden über dauer lockdown während
andere impfen und über sommerurlaub
sprechen
wir haben da in den vergangenen tagen
viele berichte in der englischen presse
gesehen da freut man sich schon dass die
deutschen nicht nach mallorca kommen
werden weil sie weniger impfstoff haben
wie glauben sie kann sich das noch
entwickeln in den nächsten wochen und
monaten in der stimmung der bevölkerung
wenn wir eben sehen dass andere länder
besser dran sind dass andere länder aus
dem locker und irgendwann raus kommen
und wie einfach überhaupt keine
perspektive haben man sieht ja zum
beispiel in israel da wird jetzt ein lok
tor nochmal hingenommen weil man eben
auch weiß dass man schon über 40 50
prozent der bevölkerung geimpft hat wie
fatal ist dass auch für die psyche der
menschen
ich bin kein psychologe kann das
schlecht abschätzen aber in der tat ist
es so die menschen werden hier
frustriert sein weil wir halt nicht so
schnell impfen können wie wir wollen und
wie wir müssten muss man der ähnlichkeit
halte auch sagen aber auch der ansatz
ist es auch ganz dann also diese
mutation die wir jetzt haben die lassen
sich auch möglicherweise nicht so
schnell weg ihn von da es auch england
noch nicht also im sicheren bereich die
südafrikanische variante beispielsweise
spricht auf einige der impfstoff sehr
beschränkt an und von daher also
hat jedes land also noch in den nächsten
monaten schwierigkeiten haben auch die
länder die geimpft haben werden nicht
komplett öffnen können weil ich einfach
mit diesen impfstoffen würdig schnellen
also im für die schnellen mutationen die
herden die mobilität nicht darstellen
kann mit den impfstoffen die wir derzeit
haben ich mache mal ganz simpel wenn die
südafrikanische variante sich mit der
britischen kombiniert und breitet sich
stark auf die skalen impfstoff in der
derzeit im feld haben wahrscheinlich
stark genug um über impfung allein
werden immunität darzustellen und dann
wird es auch immer wenn auch begrenzte
einschränkungen im öffentlichen leben
geben müssen aber herr lauterbach
bedeutet das dass wir im schlimmsten
fall vielleicht jetzt diese impfung
bekommen und dann schnellstmöglich schon
wieder ein anderer impfstoff hergestellt
werden muss der eben auch auf diese
mutationen dann reagiert oder wird am
ende trotzdem dieser impfstoff reichen
wenn dann hier in deutschland und
weltweit möglichst viele menschen
geimpft sind wenn sie jetzt gerade sagen
beispielsweise südafrikanische variante
reagiert gar nicht so gut auf diesen
impfstoff also die wahrscheinlichkeit
dass wir mit dem stoff den wir jetzt für
ihn verlangt dass die über die runden
kommen
aus meiner sicht gleichwohl also die
wahrscheinlichkeit dass wir noch einmal
den füssen mit anderen impfstoffen
verbesserten impfstoff oder zumindest
mit sogenannten booster impfstoffen das
dritte los ist das ist aus meiner sicht
mit sicherheit zu erwarten und wird
derzeit im übrigen von den unter
entsprechenden unternehmen darauf
vorbereitet ist da ganz kurz ein haken
weil das ist tatsächlich man muss fast
sagen nur horror nachricht wenn sie
sagen der impfstoff jetzt ihrer meinung
nach wird es auf jeden fall nicht
ausreichen müssen wir da eigentlich
anfang dass wir jetzt noch das nächste
jahr immer wieder in den locker umgehen
egal ob selbst vier jungen jetzt
schnellstmöglich dem vom bekommen oder
nicht also wenn sie sagen dieser
impfstoff reicht so oder so nicht was
machen wir dann jetzt gerade inwiefern
geht es denn jetzt überhaupt weiter dann
ist man gar nicht wenn lok dann von
einem weiteren monat sprechen sondern
das klingt fast danach bis wir den
nächsten impfstoff haben
ja und ich glaube nicht dass man bis
dahin im lokal muss man wird
systematisch auch dinge wieder öffnen
können und das wird wird es
entsprechende konzepte geben aber man
muss die bevölkerung auch also ehrlich
aufklären über die lage und die lage
die dass wir also mit dieser ersten
impfung die wir jetzt macht dann
wahrscheinlich nicht gegen alle
varianten ausreichend eben können somit
wird auf jeden fall eine neue empfunden
notwendig seien und das sage ich jetzt
deshalb weil das natürlich dann
schneller gehen muss als in der ersten
runde daher hatte ich auf ihre frage
geantwortet was ist jetzt sagen was zu
kritisieren
ich könnte sie ja gar nichts sagen sie
gefragt was ist nötig da habe ich gesagt
wir müssen schneller sein
wir müssen mehr im kapazität ausbauen
damit wird bei der nächsten runde viel
schneller impfstoff produzieren können
und auch sehr viel schneller informieren
auch die logistik muss beschleunigt
werden das ist das was wir jetzt
vorbereiten müssen müssen quasi mit der
ersten runde impfung die zweite bereits
vorberaten dass wir aus man dass sich
die vorhersehen der denkweise
das bedeutet aber nicht dass wir bis zur
zweiten impfung im locker und leiden
müssen sondern es wird bestimmte
einschränkungen geben müssen das kommt
aber sehr stark darauf an welche
varianten sich hier verbreiten und da
kann ich auch einen rat geben wir müssen
ganz besonders auf die südafrikanische
variante oder die kombination von der
britischen und der südafrikanischen
variante achten war das ist genau die
kombination die also dazu führen wird
dass die impfungen und auch die
vorgehabt infektionen übrigen nicht
ausreichend schützt aber laut aabar wird
reden wir über die südafrikanische und
mutationen von paar wochen haben wir
über die britische gesprochen vielleicht
kommt bleibt die argentinische die
venezolanische die italienische mutation
das sind ja dann horrorszenarien die
doch wieder bedeuten könnten dass es
eben politiker gibt die argumentieren
dass wir dann eine endlos ewig dauern
lockdown bleiben oder aufmachen und
wieder zu machen
wann glauben sie ist der punkt erreicht
wo man sagen muss wir halten das nicht
mehr aus weil die schäden auf der
anderen seite wir erleben das jetzt
schon bei kindern die psychologischen
schäden aber auch ganz klassisch
menschen die nicht ins krankenhaus gehen
weil sie sorge haben von corona die
geschehen für die gesellschaft die
milliarden schulden die auf uns zukommen
dass all diese dinge irgendwann so groß
sind dass wir das nicht mehr durchhalten
wann ist dieser punkt erreicht aus ihrer
sicht
aber seien wir sie wissen ja dass ich
also offen auch über dinge bereit bin zu
sprechen ich schwierig zu vermitteln
sind wenn es also politik und auch
epidemiologisch geboten ist und daher
also können sie sicher sein ein solches
szenario sehe ich nicht das wildauer
lockdown sind so dass ich ständig immer
wieder den lockdown müssen die impfungen
die jetzt gegeben werden die wirken
gegen die mutationen nicht perfekt aber
sie haben an der wirkung und mit der
also plattform von der ich eben
gesprochen habe dass man impfstoffe sehr
schnell anpassen kann und dass man sich
sehr schnell produzieren kann und auf
den vorgang beschleunigen kann können
wir eine solche horror situation wie sie
gerade also sagen mal ausgemacht haben
das können wir verhindern damit auf der
seite des hafens der guten nachricht ist
wir verstehen saß doch so gut dass wir
relativ schnell im stoff für anpassen
können
der flaschenhals ist nur die produktion
der flaschenhals ist nur das tempo der
impfung und das können wir dramatisch
beschleunigen werden wir endlich die
logistik das wir aufbauen sodass wir
auch also schneller sind in diesem
zweiten und dritten schild in otterbach
jetzt wenn wir schon bei den mutationen
sind ein weiteres thema war das wir hier
schon gesprochen haben was jetzt in
diesem entwurf auftritt steht die
inzidenz wir alle in deutschland kennen
die goldene 50 die erreicht werden muss
damit über lockerungen sprechen können
über eine art normalität die soll jetzt
vielleicht sogar runtergeschraubt werden
auf 35 und ich weiß dass auch sie schon
lange darüber sprechen dass wir einen
viel niedrigeren instanz wäre bräuchten
um wieder über lockerungen oder wenn
normalität zu sprechen
können sie uns aber irgendwie erklären
wieso zahlen jetzt zustande kommen die
50 das war einfach so die war einfach
irgendwann da angela merkel hat gesagt
dann können die gesundheitsämter die
kontakte nach verfolgen jetzt die 35
kommt dann vielleicht bald die 20 und
dann die 10 auf was kann sich die
menschen tatsächlich verlassen oder
vorbereiten welchen wert wir alle
zusammen jetzt schaffen müssen damit es
dann endlich wieder öffnungen gibt also
ist ja ganz klar wenn das virus also
deutlich ansteckender geworden ist und
das ist ja jetzt so was die britische
variante die wir auch bekommen
und die wird die ursprungs variante auch
in deutschland komplett verdrängen also
werden in ein paar monaten werden wir
also genau wie andere länder die
britische variante fast ausschließlich
haben die verdrängte war ja die alte
variante wird durch die britische
variante verdrängt werden das wird auch
bei uns passieren da haben wir quasi mit
einem neuen virus zu tun was also über
einen monat gesprochen also vier bis
achtmal so ansteckend ist wir brauchen
viel weniger virus um sich zu infizieren
wo sie zum beispiel einem raum sich
derzeit infizieren wenn jemand mit so
viren im raum sitzt und das dauert 15
minuten brauchen sie hier +34 vielleicht
maximal fünf minuten ist es anfangs sehr
viel einstecken da das wissen wir
dann muss ich natürlich auch den
incidents wert anpassen auf denen ich
also hier abhebe und somit ist mal
ausmalen dass ich das sage ich aber
schon seit monaten wie 25 das neue 50
das ist einfach so weil ich bei den
logisch kamera platten dann ist man
einigermaßen schnell im entdecken von
ausbrüchen kann die sehr schnell
begrenzen
und wenn man das kombinieren würde mit
einem erwerb unter 0,7 dann also hat man
auch diese gefährliche schnell war jan
timke daher würde ich auch immer wie
folgt argumentieren ich würde mich jedes
mal ein neues datum nennen was dann
tatsächlich nicht gehalten wird sondern
ich wurde eine klare linie vorgeben die
landkreise die die kombination 25 mit
einem mehrwert unter 0,7 erreicht haben
das sind die lockerungen dann auch
möglich weil da kriege ich das geschehen
dann auch schnell in den griff dass wir
aus meiner sicht auch viel einfacher zu
kommunizieren der botschaft und dies
auch wissenschaftlich gesichert weil
unter 0,7 das ist der entscheidende
werte er wird unter 0,7 wächst auch die
schnelle neue britische mutation nicht
weiter sie kann sich da nicht
exponentiell aus denen dann habe ich das
problem im griff
herr lauterbach zum abschluss eine kurze
frage die menschen wollen ja wieder raus
sie wollen wieder was erleben was
glauben sie wann darf ich mit nele in
den biergarten gehen wieder ein bier
trinken wann darf ich mich zum wahl zum
abschied umarmt wann wird s mal wieder
ein bisschen normal auf der welt also
hängt sehr davon ab was jetzt in den
nächsten monaten passiert also das hängt
sehr stark davon abhängen
es uns gelingt mit lokalen und impfung
schnelles impfen gründlicher lockdown
nicht zu früh öffnen intelligent öffnen
wie eben beschrieben
ob es uns gelingt zumindest also die
kombination der britischen und der
südafrikanischen variante in deutschland
auf distanz zu halten wenn wir sehr viel
bekommen von der südafrikanischen
variante und die impfstoffe nicht
perfekt wirken
dann wird auch der sommer nicht so
normal sein wie wir uns das alle
wünschen
das muss man der ehrlichkeit dazu geben
aber wir haben das jetzt noch in der
hand
vielen dank karl lauterbach für ihre
sehr drastische aber ehrliche
einschätzung zudem wie die kommenden
monate hier in deutschland dann aussehen
dankeschön dankeschön